alors j'espère que l'équipe parce que
j'ai peur que braga mais jamais aussi
bas depuis mai - ont fait défaut ces
désinvestissements ont noté les gens au
ont fait le gendarme et or et tout ça
pour quoi
ou encore nous gouverner avant
[Musique]
on commence à en avoir ras le bol quand
je vais avoir des potes qui vont se
tirer une balle dans la tête parce que
la cour ils ont pu rouvrir un sou déjà
vent dans la misère totale
il ya des gens qui vont tout perdre et
tout un secteur est en train de mourir
oui mais toujours là qui meurent aussi
du duc on avait juste mais nous sommes
heureux de boulot notre canton pas être
à l écoute
[Musique]
vous